foreign
[Music]
but let's face it it's a complicated
game guys soccer as you like to call it
is like life next season I think we have
a real shot
I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell you
you're you're fired
good news is you got two options option
one that's where you're currently at or
American Samoa are you serious
we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team go
let's start again humiliation mark my
words things are going to change I got
us a new coach
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and wine
safe to say
or understanding of the game
so they're not right about this guy what
he is white
coach you got
you got the job on the island
what we want is just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
I can't work with these guys for them
it's like some sort of game it is a game
Palace
giant leadership
leadership
dear Lord thank you for sending us Mr
rongan we've become quite attached to
him it's like finding a little lost
white kid at the mall and telling him
which way to go
[Music]
foreign